um you you were cool with chris delia
right
i've heard him talk about you yeah
what's going on with this guy man
you know i don't have that information
have you spoken with him since this [ __ ]
popped off man because this
listen i don't know what happened but
either way the guy just
the guy did just have a baby yeah you
know he's got
he's got a girl and a baby and you know
if
if this is the the version of what
happened is
the version where he didn't do any of
this stuff
then [ __ ] i you got to feel i mean [ __ ]
that sucks man
yeah that's what i'm saying like it's
it's a weird thing you know like that's
why like
i'm not one of those people that like i
don't jump into a group
thing i don't i don't think correctly i
don't
i can't think in a group format i have
to step away
from [ __ ] to like understand it from
like myself and then i go
well what what is this information right
what can i do with this information
and then it's like oh you know then you
kind of like
you know dwindle it down you know um
uh yeah as far as that goes you know
yeah like like that's why i had to get
away from the social media world because
like like
like well like as far as twitter and
like facebook because when yeah when you
go on it you just see like
the [ __ ] and this is supposed to be
correct and i'm like bro i read books
like why the [ __ ] am i like looking at
this [ __ ] for you know something correct
and um
you know um i was just like
listen you know i've never known him
to do any of that yeah do any of that
you haven't had any
communication with him since everything
popped off yeah i reached out to him
yeah i did you know and and and i and i
you know it was weird because i i hate
the fact that like
i was letting social media like define
that if i should or not
right right you know where it's like you
know and i had i had a long time i
had a long talk with my my girl about it
you know
and she was like he's the first dude you
meant comedy you know like
he you know so he was the first guy you
met in comedy he was the first guy i met
in comedy what year was that
that was uh 2011. oh wow
yeah you met crystal lee in 2011 he
wasn't even like
anything this was before he was that
justin bieber's favorite comment yeah
yeah this is before before that and so
this is a guy who like
did he help did he kind of serve as a
mentor at all to you like in the comedy
[ __ ] everybody uh yeah he yeah he helped
me out with some stuff man he uh
you know he's letting me open for him
you know which like you know he has some
like
the craziest fans craziest fans in like
dopest audience
you know and um um
yeah man i yeah i i've so i've reached
out to him and
you know my girl was like you shouldn't
feel guilty about that yeah
yeah i mean you know you know like i
mean look you're his friend you should
give the benefit of the doubt
yeah exactly and and there's and there's
nothing she's like there's nothing wrong
with that
you know like you're you're not you're
not a judge you're not a you know
that's that's not your lane um but i was
just like you know i reached out to him
i
i said i'm probably the you know
on the lowest lowest part of the totem
pole of people you want to hear from
right now but
you know i just send positivity your way
man